a poignant commemoration of the moment
75 years ago when the world entered the
atomic age
and a whole city was destroyed with the
numbers of the so-called hibakusha
the original survivors of the attack
declining each year
this is likely to be the last major
anniversary
they will attend in large numbers
special precautions in place
to protect them from the coronavirus but
hiroshima's mayor referred to
as a new threat facing the world
accompanied by a worrying increase
in nationalism
we must never allow this painful path to
repeat itself
civil society must reject self-centered
nationalism
and unite against all threats
at 8 15 in the morning local time a
single atomic bomb
codenamed little boy exploded 2 000
feet above the center of the city
killing tens of thousands of people
instantly
with tens of thousands more dying in the
months and years that followed
many from radiation related illnesses
michiko kodama was a child when the bomb
was dropped
with the pandemic innovative ways have
been found
for her and other survivors to share
their stories with the present
generation
[Laughter]
there is a sense that we don't have much
longer to live
i'm now 82 i don't know when i won't be
able to speak
so in some form we need to preserve our
stories
three days after hiroshima nagasaki was
attacked with a second bomb
another anniversary with more survivors
to market
and in both cities both among the
generation who endured the attacks and
also the generations that came after
them
there's a strong peace culture that's
really focused on
abolishing nuclear weapons the
experience of being the only country to
be attacked with nuclear weapons
helped shape modern japan
by urging action from each country japan
will take the lead in the international
community's efforts towards the
realization of a world without nuclear
weapons
it's a goal still far from being
realized
but one held still as strongly in the
two cities that have suffered most from
such weapons
rob mcbride al jazeera